[Music]
this youtube video that's gone viral uh
in the last couple of days everybody's
talking about it and some of you
probably seen it too in the video a very
angry woman appears to be stealing
rhubarb
from someone's garden and uh yeah it's
she's really a piece of work here's a
clip
pinocchio i know somebody don't business
why don't you why not do you why don't
you take some food why don't you call
your own
this is not your property go somewhere
else where's your name [ __ ] where's
your name where's your name where's my
name where's your name on this alley
property
unbelievable everybody's talking about
this woman i personally was surprised
that people were just hearing about this
lady now in the last couple of days
because she's been a menace here on the
warner brothers lot
for years in fact just this morning i
cut her going through my own personal
supply of rhubarb we happen to have a
camera crew handy check it out
hey excuse me
excuse me this is my rhubarb dear [ __ ]
ellie probably got yours
no this is my rhubarb actually this is
you [ __ ] ain't got your name on it
clearly has my name on it i i've made a
sign you don't own this just go back
inside
okay can you just go back inside you
want your language this is a you bet
you call me [ __ ] i'm a man and i i
don't i don't know
you're a man well what are you coming on
some kind of
now
okay you shouldn't
harry brock it's my rhubarb
she's got a point
[Laughter]